occupy wall street is back baby we got a
post here from gavin
mario wax who says the new york young
republicans
club will be staging a protest in
zuccotti park to reoccupy wall street
we are sick and tired of bailing out the
fat cats and hedge funds for their own
mistakes
while they stomp on the little guy for
trying to make a buck this is not
capitalism and then we have this from
eventbrite
let the people trade in quotes reoccupy
wall street sunday january 31st at noon
zuccotti park so just keep it cool
don't nobody so just keep it cool it
doesn't need to be about politics this
is about the little guy yeah
and gao that's what i'm trying to say
keep it about the little guy and little
gao
i think this is an area that we can all
kind of come together we have rasheeda
talaib
and alexandria cortez and even um
ted cruz yeah ted cruz is in on it
complaining and saying that the robin
hood thing
they should be investigated now for what
they did well so it is political
well and i'm not confident they'll do
anything right but
before we get away from too much from
the from the from the zuccotti stuff
we have the story from the new york post
nyc protesters slam robin hood scream at
wall street traders amid game stop
stock chaos apparently people are
showing up physically outside of wall
street
tax the rat rich invest in our new york
it's getting it's it's it's everybody
trump supporters you go to you go to
patriots.win where it's the old you know
donald trump form
they're all in they're just like
cheering and clapping
then you look at these socialist forms
they're cheering dude it's so funny on
twitter for the first time i was going
down the list i saw tim
tweeting and complaining about it about
uh i don't know with nokia
vosh tweeting complaining about it the
exact same thing i was like yes we've
unified
dang maybe i feel like i'm i'm in the
out group right now maybe i need to
cook up a fire tweet about it are you
cheering on the hedge funds
no not that i'm just saying like i feel
like i haven't spoken i don't have much
to say about it
i know you do i mean i always support
the plebs
i'm a prep so i always support the plebs
i want the little guy to win i want the
underdog to win
that's my entire like energy in life i
always want the underdog to win
my thing is like you know pure
capitalism like like capitalism in its
pure form
is supposed to be that people freely
trade with each other right and then
let's say
ian figures out this really great
graphene
polymer substance and all of us are like
dude we need some of that so we all
give ian money to buy it and now ian's
got all this money and i'm just like
that's awesome congratulations for you
know your success
congratulations shout out to the
graphene this is great yeah wait did you
actually
wait wait wait back up did i miss a joke
like is that an actual thing that
yeah yeah well no no like like ian loves
graphene so i'm just making a point
about
what's graphene oh it's pure carbon so
so it's hexagonally laced carbon
i won't bring it up okay we can go into
it later in the show
feather stiff as a board now i'm seeing
this um it's going to be like this this
witch powder come out
listen we'll treat it like amanda deal
of the time
i may not come find me i'll just play it
sorry
so my point is though what we're seeing
now is not capitalism in its pure form
we're seeing people lie on tv and get
their buddies to lie so they can steal
money from people now you have a bunch
of people who have gotten rich
who've contributed absolutely nothing
but i i haven't put the line past day
traders like there are people who trade
and make money off trading
assuming risk but then making money not
producing a whole lot
right but we're not i'm not even
complaining about that i'm complaining
about these companies these
these firms and these funds that rig the
system and manipulate to cheat
and they get away with it every single
time until now
well actually maybe they will i mean
they're still on the hook for you know
billions of dollars
we'll see with with the the halting of
trading on these stocks
of purchasing the prices did go down but
a lot of people are saying just don't
sell
they won't let you buy don't sell if
there's no supply
they can't buy they can't pay back their
you know the lenders for the shorts and
they're gonna they're gonna burn
essentially
you know i think the point i was making
earlier
we saw that the game you know that they
were cheating but we still thought that
we
we could we could get past that you know
what i mean
i guess i guess now we're realizing that
they're they're cheating to the point
where
if you get even close to beating them
while they're cheating they flip the
board
yep they should throw in the garbage and
we have individuals like
ted cruz agreeing with alexandria
ocasio-cortez
ted cruz literally retweeted aoc and
said
i'm with this and but then what did she
do hold on but hold on
before we even get there this is
spectacular that we have so many people
on the opposite political spectrum
saying whoa this is messed up this is
not not right at all
and then of course alexandria
ocasio-cortez who was treating a whole
bunch of divisive race stuff the entire
day who tweeted about it once
slapped him back and then accused him of
trying to murder her i mean
how hyperbolic how sensational how
utterly ridiculous
can you get you have a moment in time
when the left and the right are finally
coming together seeing things clearly
seeing things get
together against the special interest
and then you have alexandria cortes
screaming
hey he tried to kill me are you kidding
me are you kidding me now
now you got to pull these cards out and
then listen if she really believed
uh ted cruz wanted a killer why didn't
she press charges you look
look at what she was even tweeting i
will support a hearing if necessary what
do you mean if necessary
of course it's nice rasheeda toled was
like we must do this and i was like yes
preach and ted lou was like how is this
possible like yes sir naoc was like i'm
thinking about it
and i was like all right all right like
sure and then she went
ted cruz tried to murder me and i'm like
dude she
she you know what man that's why i do
not like her she is a shill
she is she is a she is a careerist
you've got
people on the left and people on the
right all cheering you know
watching the hedge funds burn and she
comes out
and starts slinging mud distracting
everybody once again
and i tweeted this watch out for those
that are bringing up race and rage bait
issues to distract you from the great
gamestop rebellion
this is history being made right now the
people have found their power
they have focused their little iron
cannons but together it creates that
massive beam
everybody it's like it's like goku's
spirit bomb and dragon ball z
everybody's giving their energy
to make this massive powerful blast and
she's going no no everybody don't look
at that ted cruz tried to murder me
and be like me me me me look at me i'm a
victim
i mean come on i mean seriously that to
go there
at this point in time is just this is
crazy literally
this is this is what liza's talking
about she's talking about not tainting
this movement with stuff like politics
and race like what happened with
operation wall street
we want to keep it clean straight
populist serious about what you're
actually pursuing and and unified
like why would you break it down along
race barriers why would you be aoc
screaming at ted cruz
it's it's because she is a clap back
personality that's it
yes so she her whole shtick is the
republicans
so listen i'll be the first to admit i
had a really good impression
look i reckon democrats all day and
night
all right and i'll criticize mitch
mcconnell lindsey graham and a bunch of
republicans as well and i rag on them
too but i do rag on democrats way more
and this is the perfect example you've
got people on the right like rand paul
you've got well you used to have people
on the left like tulsi gabbard and she's
not there anymore
but for the most part there's several
people thomas massey rand paul
you can you can call them and say the
republicans have some people that are
doing
doing well and they're staying on
principle then you look at the left and
you've got nancy pelosi who is
she's like a sludge monster of of
corporate grime that
builds up on the bottom of one of their
freight trucks as they ship their
corporate
pollution yes good morning sunday
morning good
morning and then you have sunday morning
aoc is supposed to be
the the insurgent candidate coming in
and
and changing everything and what does
she do she just dangles the keys in
front of the left
and then what happens is when she says
ted cruz you tried to have me murdered
all of these leftists who were focused
on on hedge funds turn and go
yeah slay queen you tell ted cruz and
i'm like no no no no no no no
ted cruz is giving you his power the
[ __ ] don't
she said quote i am happy to work with
republicans on this issue where there's
common ground but you almost had me
murdered
three weeks ago so you can sit this one
out
there going on and saying happy to work
with almost any other gop
that aren't trying to get me killed in
the meantime if you want to help you can
resign
oh my god and then all of a sudden all
of these lefties are distracted and
their attention is turned what aoc just
did here
was she fired a flare to distract the
masses from
the game stop but she fired the flare at
ted cruz which isn't where you're
supposed to fire a flare no
no no no ted cruz is pointing at the
hedge funds and yelling charge and hold
the line
and then she turns and points at him and
says no get him and i'm like wait a
minute
you're telling people to [ __ ] to fire at
the guy who's standing alongside us
she is the shill now i'm not i'm not
saying she represents
these these corporate interests or
anything necessarily but the game she
plays
manipul listen you know what you know
what i was thinking you can really
figure out who the real grifters are
right now
i was looking at twitter and i saw some
people posting about culture war stuff
when the the capital riot was happening
and i'm like
what it what is this why are you why are
you posting about this
when we're watching the people storm the
capitol building
do you really care about what's
happening in this country or are you
just pushing
your one cause because it's what you
know and how you know how to make
followers and make money
i thought when you'd see something like
the capital being stormed
that would capture everyone's attention
as americans but no
now we see this with with gamestop and
with the hedge funds
and i thought much the same thing there
are a lot of people i know who talk
about
critical race theory and stuff and
they're tweeting about this and critical
race theory
and then there are people like aoc who
tweets very little until people start
tweeting at her and then she tweets
about it tepidly
and then starts attacking ted cruz again
and i'm like you you really don't care
about the people do you
your whole thing is i'm going to milk
the culture war
to rally a bunch of people who hate ted
cruz and it works
but did she actually feel i mean i'm not
even trying to be funny in the slightest
i
because i don't know the story but my
best friend told me i was too close to
the mic she told me to sit back she told
me i was too loud just saying
anyway um no so i i just don't know did
she actually feel like her life was in
danger
and i'm not trying to funny i'm not
trying to be funny i'm being legit
serious because in my world
in the in the movement that i in the
space that i hang out in
that's like not a funny thing to joke
about no so
you get what i'm saying i'm not trying
to be of course not but to blame it on
ted cruz who believes in a different
political opinion on you is a little
disingenuous in my opinion
i think that's a good point though she's
probably suffering from some sort of
post-traumatic did she actually
she's like ted i'm not trying to be
funny like well
she feels like ted cruz supported the
movement that tried to have her kids was
she almost killed in
that situation in her mind yes but
realistically
it turns out no but they didn't know
that in the moment because people were
storming in there
screaming and smashing windows so
perhaps
and listen i'm no by no means a fan
trust me i'm not a fan i'm just playing
devil's advocate like is there a chance
that she actually felt like her life
because there's some stressful times and
if somebody came in here right now even
if it was one of your friends
if you guys knew them but if i didn't i
might feel a type of way and be like oh
i'm about to yeah especially if i was
somebody that was i mean let's just say
alex jones
but why else came in and i didn't know
who he was and he came in all hot
on 10 and i didn't know who he was i
would be like oh my gosh i might so i
might feel that anxiety
surrounded by capital police being
ushered up before anybody comes in
and why should she feel that way what in
her life has led her to experience that
kind of trauma
no i think the look you're allowed to be
scared and you're allowed to be
inexperienced
but you're not allowed to claim that ted
cruz almost had you murdered
simply because he said some words one
time is that something you're allowed to
say on twitter
yeah hmm yeah twitter yeah
i mean i guess if you're on the left
you're allowed to say a lot of things on
twitter you'll have to organize violence
because they still do
i could say i will see why she said it
because i think she is suffering from
from a form of ptsd having the capital
been assaulted
but i don't think that justifies
saying that as a politician i think
she's in the wrong doing that i
i think she's being a cynical politician
and she wants that clap back i
no i just think the only thing she's
like the one thing she's figured out
is that by she's she's anti-republican
that's her whole position
i can't tell you what she's for because
she flip-flops she's just like hey the
republicans are bad it's like okay
i hear you now is not the time how is
the time when i talk about it
i'm trying as hard as possible to be
like rasheeda to labe nails it she's
awesome
well she's been surprising lately she
went out against the patriot act 2.0 now
she's making these statements and i
never thought i would say this but i
agree with russia to leave on these
issues and uh
it's not it's a good good honor for for
not playing party politics and standing
up for actual issues that that do matter
and do affect us and that's very rare
i gotta say i'm actually i'm actually a
fan right now you know why because
i i know i don't agree with her and i
know i don't like her attitude when she
yelled impeached the mother effer
but i can see when she calls out robin
hood
when she when she says no national
security powers i'm like
right on you believe what you want to
believe i'll disagree with you but i
like that you stand up for what you
believe in and i like that you believe
what you believe
and i like that you're challenging the
system in a legitimate way aoc is not
doing that
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time